his take on current affairs
a couple of weeks ago he received an
ominous email
an influencer agency based in london
contacted me which
is not unusual but what was strange was
in their very first email they said we
have some information here
that we would like you to disseminate
and we'll pay you for it
they asked him to discredit biontech and
reference supposedly secret information
that allegedly proves hundreds of people
have died from its vaccination
he played along and took up their offer
to find out more
i later got further instructions saying
for example that my posts
should come across as personal opinions
and that i should not mark them with
sponsored posts
which by the way is illegal in germany
and that i should say that i came across
this information myself
around the world youtubers are being
offered money in similar circumstances
like leo garcia who lives in france we
are at the center
of of something going on like
information war and people need to be
super super cautious of what they
read about what they hear about france's
health minister responded sharply to
these attempts to manipulate public
opinion
the vast majority of french people want
to be vaccinated
and i don't think anyone from france or
abroad can dissuade the french
with such a negative communication
campaign
according to research by german
broadcaster ard
youtubers from other countries have
already spread the dubious information
in india for example so here there are
two companies who provide vaccination
this brazilian youtuber is also seen
warning viewers against what he calls
the dangerous vaccine
there are lots of famous people out
there who will do almost anything for
cash
it's dangerous especially when it comes
to things like elections
influencers are being paid to place
certain messages
daniel laufer an editor at germany's
netspolitik.org news site has been
researching the issue
it's interesting that this company
doesn't even exist in the british
commercial register
it's a dummy company that doesn't even
have a doorbell at the address provided
and we found its customers seem by and
large mostly to be russian
miyako drochmann stopped researching the
topic
the supposed agency apparently figured
out he was leading them on
and cut all contact
[Music]
and we want to continue the discussion
with investigative journalist daniel
laffer who we just saw
in that report daniel welcome the
burning question raised in that report
is who is behind this campaign and so we
ask i guess who benefits
from the spread of this misinformation
it's not entirely clear who's behind it
but
where is this in general hard to say who
might
benefit from this information in this
case i think it's rather obvious
you have a case where someone is trying
to undermine trust
in a vaccine in which a lot of people in
the western world
are putting a lot of hope into they
basically are trying
to make it look as if the governments
were hiding something
the people behind this campaign wanted
the influences to claim that the media
was hiding it as well
so whoever is behind this wants
to create a situation in which it seems
like
um the western world is doing something
really
dangerous with their vaccine and of
course if you look at the situation in
russia with their campaign
in terms of their vaccine and not
developing the way they might have had
hoped it would
it seems possible that it's coming from
there we found traces
to russia in terms of the company that's
behind
this disinformation campaign and also if
you look at this twitter account for
sputnik v
the russian vaccine it has been
spreading similar messaging
to this disinformation campaign now for
weeks
daniel how much of an effect can
individual influencers have on
changing public opinion
you need to think about the way
influencers usually
work i mean they start talking
to their viewers directly they build up
an image where they become
something like perhaps a big brother or
big sister to their viewers so they have
a lot of trust and if
your big brother or your big sister
tells you something about their opinion
you of course
listen you take it very seriously this
is not like some
remote ad that's being shown to you this
is someone who you
really have a connection to or you think
you have a connection to telling you
something
which eventually might change your
political views which might uh
change the way that you feel about this
vaccine in this case
so i think if they actually succeeded
this campaign
which they did in some cases at least i
think it might have a great effect even
though it's hard to actually measure it
yeah we've been asking for a long time
now it seems what is being done
and what can be done to stop this
deliberate spread
of misinformation
the problem is it's very hard to
regulate it because
there's a thin line and if you cross it
you're basically
committing censorship and you do not
want to censor freedom of speech this is
not at all what you want to do obviously
so this
obviously means that you have to accept
a lot of things that are out there
that might be
wrong opinions in this case it's about
facts it's more easy
but the thing is also if you look at the
way they did it they took
real numbers and then put them into a
wrong context
so to figure out what was actually wrong
with those numbers you would have to
thoroughly fact
check this campaign this takes time
and eventually you need to draw this
conclusion
this is not something that you can
notice right away when just looking at
it
because it pops up in your feed so even
let's say if the platforms then reacted
to it and eventually took it down
and sanctioned the people spreading it
it would still mean that the message had
already gotten out
right and this makes it very hard to
actually uh
yeah somehow contaminate
contain this kind of kind of spread of
this information
daniel lover thanks so much
thank you